- All right, y'all, we've got
time for one last quick story
that will put a smile
on your face hopefully.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(cheery music)
(audience claps)
So, mamas, all of us
at one point have felt
like the worst parent on earth,
and if you haven't, that's
probably cuz you are (laughs).
(audience laughs)
Whether it's forgetting to
pack a diaper bag (laughs),
serving your kid chicken
nuggets five days in a row,
you've done it, or letting
your kid play Roblox
for, I don't know, four hours straight,
cuz you just needed a minute.
We've all been there.
I haven't.
I'm perfect,
but you've been there maybe.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
So in solidarity, let's
spare some sympathy
for a Minnesota mama who
realized, this is amazing,
after years, years,
that she was celebrating
her son's birthday (laughs)
on the wrong date.
(audience groans)
Take a look.
- I just got off the phone
with my pediatrician.
She's trying to bill our last visit
to our insurance company.
Per my words, "My son's
birthday is the 26th.
"I'm his mother.
"I know his birthday."
The insurance company says,
"No, his birthday's on the 25th."
For two years, I've been
celebrating his birthday
on the 26th.
You wanna know the worst part?
The worst part.
It's my middle child.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience groans and claps)
- Oh, my God.
The best part of that
is my sister is going
to love that part.
She's the middle child, the bereft child,
everything didn't happen for her.
We have that mom, Emily,
on the line right now.
Oh, my gosh.
Emily, I love you.
(audience cheers)
- Oh, my gosh.
- This is so funny.
I've just never heard of it.
So wait, your insurance company is
actually how you found out
that you were celebrating
your son's birthday
on the wrong day.
- Yes, so my pediatrician's
office calls me
cuz she can't bill the visit.
The birthdate I gave her is wrong is
what the insurance company is saying,
and I was about to call
the insurance company
and give them a piece of my
mind cuz I know his birthday.
I'm his mother.
(Kelly laughs)
But before I called them, I thought
maybe I should scroll back
Facebook just to make sure.
And sure enough, the insurance
company had it right.
Of course, they did (Emily laughs).
And it made stickin' national news,
my mom fail, heard 'round the world.
Gosh.
(Kelly laughs)
- Wait, that's the best part too.
You didn't like fail alone though.
Your husband didn't know either.
(Emily groans in disgust)
- If this was my husband's mistake,
it wouldn't be national news.
(Kelly laughs)
I asked him the other night,
do you know any of our kids' birthdays?
And, we have four kids, and
he got the birth months right,
but zero of the dates.
So.
(Kelly cackles)
- You're like, so you know what?
Crawl under this bus
with me, sir (laughs).
I was like, oh my God, I love it.
This is one of my favorite
mom fails I've ever heard of.
I love you so much.
Congratulations.
It's his birthday today as well.
I'm claiming it.
This is Henry's birthday as well.
I'm liking your post right now, okay?
(bell dings)
It's just never not
gonna be funny (laughs).
Oh, my God.
Okay, so that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
wanna honor mamas just like you
cuz you're working hard at it.
You got a lot of kids, girl.
Congratulations, they're
gonna write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
(audience cheers)
- Oh, my gosh.
I did not know this.
- See, your mom fail paid off.